if you've been itching for a vacation
you're not alone
summer holiday travel has surged to
levels not seen since before the covet
19 pandemic
the consumer price index which is the
benchmark measure of inflation
rose 0.9 percent in june the largest
one-month increase
since 2008 vacation-related expenses
weren't spared
prices increased for everything from new
cameras and swimsuits to rental cars and
hotel rooms
were just have this kind of collective
need to get out and about
experts say price increases reflect an
economy on the upswing from pandemic
lows
but higher demand has made some vacation
essentials harder to come by
here's why that is in some strategies to
help avoid the sticker shock
as lockdowns have eased summer holiday
travel has surged both
in the air and on the ground triple a
says more than 47 million people
traveled over the fourth of july holiday
weekend
which is 40 percent more than last year
but u.s air travel is still recovering
after the pandemic drove it to
a virtual standstill much of the
recovery lag has to do with the slow
return of business travel
however airlines prepared for an almost
normal schedule of flights this summer
as leisure travel demand returned
contributing to airfare increasing
nearly 25
since last year if you're looking for
cheaper airfare
wsj travel editor debra dunn suggests
switching up
when you fly the key to finding a less
expensive airfare is to be really
flexible
not just traveling on a weekend
or traveling from a saturday to sunday
but i would look at the price difference
if you fly on a tuesday or wednesday
but once you're all booked and touched
down at your destination
you still may hit those higher prices
vehicle rental prices are up
over 87 from a year ago the simple
reason is that rental companies
have less cars smaller rental fleets had
one big issue
summer demand surged over 300 in some
cities
according to kayak this has led some
travelers being turned away at the
rental counter because there aren't
enough cars on the lot
and with a semi-conductor shortage
continuing to hamper new car production
some analysts think it will be well into
2022 before fleet supplies are enough to
meet demand
book months and months ahead and i
wouldn't
book a non-refundable uh
reservation the other possibility is to
look at picking up a car in town rather
than in the airport
you'll have to take an uber from the
airport but it's still day to day
probably a better deal those with their
own set of wheels could count themselves
lucky if they weren't
facing the steepest gasoline prices in
nearly seven years
as gas shortages have plagued many
regions the colonial pipeline cyber
attack in may led to east coast
shortages right before the summer season
and some regions of the country have had
a hard time restocking gas stations
because of a lack of truck drivers
many of whom had been laid off during
the pandemic according to analysts
in the high prices aren't restricted to
travel expenses
men's and women's swimwear prices were
up 1.4 and 5.5 percent
respectively which analysts attribute to
pent up vacation demand
demand outpacing supply has hit other
vacation essentials as well
like cameras which have risen in price
by almost six percent
and depending on where your head hits
the pillow you could be paying more for
accommodations
room rates have recovered to
pre-pandemic levels
but the slow return of business travel
has kept occupancy rates slightly lower
than before the pandemic
according to analysts and while demand
may be high in traditional destinations
like florida and hawaii
experts say price increases are being
driven by vacationers booking bigger
accommodations that may be off the
beaten path
travelers are opting for larger hotel
suites or entire rental houses to
accommodate families vacationing
together
and according to air dna which tracks
short-term rental prices of airbnb
and verbo demand in small cities in
rural locations has surged over 51
since 2019. the current vacation season
is being defined by an economy in
recovery
and a population desperate for some r r
even if it puts a dent in their wallets
be flexible about where you're going to
go when you're going to go
how long you're going to stay
flexibility i think is the operative
word this summer
the last thing you want to be is
stressed out on vacation but if prices
continue to rise
a stress-free vacation may be harder to
come by